we want to take you back 48 hours New
York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman
was a big deal then and widely respected
government official he was a feminist
icon he was regarded by many as a
potential Democratic presidential
nominee there's not a progressive cause
that Eric Schneiderman didn't embrace
wholeheartedly and then attempt to
impose by force on the people of New
York State
Shanna Martin was an all-purpose
left-wing activist he was especially an
aggressive advocate for the me2 movement
watch the challenges facing these
survivors are part of a larger system of
discrimination and really a
manifestation of a culture of male
supremacy in recent months we've begun a
long overdue recognition with our
culture of violence and silence we must
reimagine a world where predators are
exposed and held to account and
survivors are supported and empowered at
every level it really was a culture of
male supremacy said Eric Schneiderman
liberals nodded in their bovine way they
loved all of this passionately without
reservation they couldn't get enough of
Eric Schneiderman just six months ago
Samantha bee was a TV show
compared Schneiderman to a superhero
watch this it's a bird it's a plane it's
I'm Eric Schneiderman and I'm the
Attorney General of the state of New
York are you gonna lead us out of the
darkness state attorneys general we're
gonna be the first line of defense
Eric's Justice League has challenged
Trump over the first trouble banned
pesticides student loans the second
travel ban smog methane Obama care
subsidy stock on the third travel ban
trans rights green power plant of birth
control access whoo we're gonna say
there's those together you're gonna save
us we're gonna do it but that requires a
lot of people other than state attorneys
general getting engaged please you a
hero
well tonight Samantha B's hero is
disgraced and unemployed reporting by
Ronan Farrow released last night
suggested in private Schneiderman was
exactly the kind of predator he claimed
to be hunting for different women
accused Eric Schneiderman of hitting
slapping and choking them
she said they later sought medical
treatment for what he did some alleged
Schneider and made death threats against
them one says he threatened to have her
followed or her phone tapped one former
girlfriend who is Sri Lankan told
reporters that's not him in quote start
calling me his brown slave and demanding
that I repeat that I was his property
shut him ins many friends on the Left
didn't stick around long once the New
Yorker piece came out last night after
pausing to make certain that
Schneiderman's querier was really dead
former allies of croucher denounced him
and say how horrified and shocked they
are about the allegations they can't
believe it please
as with Harvey Weinstein a lot of people
knew Sneiderman was not at all what he
pretended to be there are plenty of
signs of that some public and some
people said so out loud including Donald
Trump in a famous tweet five years ago
but the left stuck with Eric
Schneiderman
anyway until the last possible moment as
they always do when political majorities
are at stake they'll put up with
anything for the sake of power principle
be damned consider this detail from the
faroe piece quote after the former
girlfriend ended the relationship with
Schneiderman she told several friends
about the abuse a number of them advised
her to keep the story to herself arguing
that Schneiderman was too valuable a
politician for the Democrats to lose if
you can even imagine and of course you
can't imagine because once again like
the obedient little robots they are
self-described champions and women fell
into line to protect an abuser of women
just as they did with Ted Kennedy and
Bill Clinton and countless others
hypocritical of course it is is it
surprising no these are the same people
who fly their private jets to global
warming conferences the ones who bring
two armed guards to anti-gun rallies
these are the people you see on
television lecturing you about diversity
from the safety of their gated
neighborhoods that look like 1950s
America are you really shocked that they
covered for a violent abuser who became
famous for denouncing domestic violence
probably not it's a familiar script
tomorrow
bed money on it they'll be blaming
Schneiderman's abuse on high school
educated men in flyover country is their
fault toxic masculinity it's a
nationwide problem that'll happen but
before it does let's be sure to get to
the bottom of this particular story who
knew about what Eric Schneiderman was
doing about what kind of man he was did
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo no how
about New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio
how about Senator and self-proclaimed me
to leader Kirsten Gillibrand all of them
supported Schneiderman's for years just
as they supported Bill Clinton and Teddy
Kennedy and Harvey Weinstein
gotten a pass for all of that this time
it's worth getting to the bottom of
their complicity in this if any